je m'appelle raphaël et je suis un élève
de 6ème année je suis un passionné
d'échecs de jeux vidéo et de sport en
classe je suis élève qui adore
travailler les mathématiques
j'aimerais vous parler d'un sujet qui me
touche beaucoup et commensaux cérébrale
ce phénomène mais touche beaucoup car
l'an dernier j'ai eu le malheur d'en
avoir deux dans un intervalle très
rapprochés à pratiquer mon sport le
hockey
de plus comme je m'intéresse au sport et
aux sportifs j'ai encore fréquemment
parlé des répercussions que peuvent
avoir les commensaux sur les athlètes
dans la vie de tous les jours
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
sujet percutant et commence au cerveau
j'ai choisi ce thème car elles sont
présentes dans le sport et j'en ai subi
de l'emporter après vous avoir exposé
comment sauver une commotion cérébrale
je vais vous expliquer les symptômes
d'une commotion cérébrale et ensuite
coiffard pour une commotion cérébrale
c'est bon fond mais ça comporte certains
risques
lorsque tu penseras une commotion
cérébrale consulte il suit les
recommandations des professionnels de la
santé
lorsque ta tête est frappé ou secouer
violemment une blessure à la tête peut
se manifester
voici quelques exemples de traumatisme
lors d'un accident de voiture sur la
tête par une balle de besoins en pleine
figure se fait plaquer dans la bande au
hockey alors qu'une blessure à la tête
subie il peut se faire des dommages car
le cerveau se déplace vite et comme dans
la boîte crânienne
heureusement dans la plupart des
commotions cérébrales disparaissent dans
les sept à dix jours suivants mais avant
tout il faut savoir la reconnaître et
avoir l'avis des professionnels
ce qui est triste c'est que la commotion
cérébrale permis de faire un problème
sur plusieurs aspects dans la vie nos
blessés il est faux de penser que pour
le monde commence au servage il faut
perdre conscience
c'est seulement dans 10% des cas à part
la perte de conscience soit si la liste
que les les symptômes qu'elle peut
affronter une personne avec une
commotion cérébrale fatigue perte
d'énergie sauf pour les forts maux de
tête nausées vomissements
étourdissements vertiges problèmes de
mémoire problèmes d'attention problèmes
de concentration sensibilité au bruit
lumière consent un problème de sommeil
il ça peut aller jusqu'aux changements
de l'humeur et de la personnel
voyez comment cela peut nous jouer des
tours après une commotion cérébrale et
est très important de se reposer
physiquement et mentalement ça veut dire
pas faire d'effort demande physique ou
du mental et avoir une bonne habitude
alimentaire et de semaine
les instructions sont les écrans comme
les jeux vidéo l'ordinateur
la tablette ensuite le sport est à voir
on fait attention brûlé lumière quand
même le blessé a perdu les symptômes
pour au moins 24 heures il pourra
recommencer le retour progressif à
l'école loisirs travail etc
si le plaisir russell le protocole avec
succès ils sont conservés les séquelles
il doit absolument prendre son temps ils
sont conservés sans brûler les étapes
voici la clé pour guérir d'une commotion
cérébrale il faut aussi retenir que la
commotion cérébrale n'est pas inévitable
mais avant tout il faut savoir la
reconnaître et avoir l'avis d'un
professionnel de santé
merci